are you familiar with uh
robert green's work 40 laws of power art
of seduction 33 strategies of war
only only as names i haven't read i
haven't read his books
okay got it he he wrote a book his last
book was
uh laws of human nature and right after
he finished his book
he had a stroke and not a not the best
kind of stroke he had a terrible stroke
and his wife had to come and pick him up
and he couldn't walk
we did an interview one time with him we
had to push him in the wheelchair to get
him it took 30 minutes before we got
ready to go through it
and i i asked him a question i said how
timely the fact and every time he was
working on the book i said how you doing
he says you know what i'm sick and my
mom's calling me telling me how's the
book i said mom stop asking me about the
book
i don't want to tell you about the book
you know the process of writing a book
for somebody as
technical as you you're not writing the
book like here's the
you know seven keys to success work hard
you know all this other stuff that maybe
you see
you know you you kind of your your brain
is uh you know
trying to get everything to be perfect i
remember one time i asked you a question
about how do you research and how do you
write
you said you write and you rewrite then
you rewrite i'm like how many times do
you write
so many times i have to write something
on and rewrite i'm like wow very
uh detailed process you go through how
heavy is it on you when you write a book
i i think the only thing i've done
that's as hard as writing is clinical
work
it's the only thing that requires as
much attention it's unbelievably
engaging but it's unbelievably difficult
and well i suppose to some degree it's
as difficult as you make it but
i'm always trying to answer questions
that i genuinely have and i'm really
trying to answer them
and i i i also so
i have a writing guide online for people
who might be interested
you can find that and it it's an
actually step-by-step
guide through what you actually have to
do if you want to write
it's not just hints about what
constitutes good writing it's a practice
manual
we're building a piece of software
called essay app
that's designed to help people write
better and therefore think better
but i mean i have an analytic approach
to writing to some degree
because i i i can write but i also know
what i'm doing when i'm writing so
imagine that a piece of work can be
analyzed
at multiple levels simultaneously did
you did you select the right word
did you select the right phrase did you
organize the phrases into the proper
sentences are
is each sentence as tightly written and
carefully argued as it possibly could be
are the sentences arranged properly in
each paragraph are the paragraphs
arranged properly in each section
are the sections arranged properly
within
each larger unit does it cohere as a
whole
is it appropriate for the time and the
place
and the audience do the sentences
sound poetic when you read them aloud do
they have a rhythm
i'm trying to answer all those questions
not at the same time but i
i try to answer all those questions with
every single word i write
and i would say i write every sentence
at least 10 or 15 times
and i mean literally i take the sentence
i put it on a separate page
and then i rewrite it multiple times and
then i pick the best sentence
and then when i do paragraph editing i
take the paragraph put it on a separate
page
break it into its sentences rearrange
the sentences
in in multiple variants and then select
the one that works the best and i do
that over and over
and so that well that's
that's so it's demanding because the
the more you get every single one of
those things right the more impact the
work has
the clearer you've made the problem and
the more also you
the other thing each like these are
books that i've written even though
there are collections of essays but
each essay stands in relationship to the
other essays
they're not independent units they they
they each add something to every other
chapter and so there's a meta meaning
that emerges that's a consequence of the
relationship between the essays and
i'm thinking about that as well when i'm
writing and trying to organize the
essays and
and it's a great for clarity of thought
and i one of the things i loved about my
conversation with jocko willink
um because he's this very masculine
very tough man very admirable person but
you know on the physical end of things
at least that's what you'd think but
he got an english degree after he was a
navy seal
and he did a 20-minute spontaneous
proclamation about the unbelievable
value of literacy
to him practically speaking you know he
said well
he has has to write out military
strategy
he has to decode orders coming from
above he has to write up commendations
for his men he has to produce
battlefield reports
he said he's noah he's nowhere at all as
powerful as he could be without
being literate and literacy is the key
to
competence in a way that is just not
properly communicated to young people
you're deadly if you're literate at
everything and it's because you
you can think and you can speak i mean
what do you have that's more than that
not there's nothing we have that's more
than that and writing
sharpens your thinking we're excited
about this app i'm you know i i
i'm really it would be wonderful if we
managed to contribute something to
make the process of writing work better
for people so that they can think more
clearly
so what it does is it helps break down
what you're writing into all these
different
uh sections so there's like a sentence
level of analysis and a paragraph level
of analysis and so forth so that
you can concentrate on one part of the
writing process at
at once instead of trying to solve all
the problems at the same time
which is so complex it'll just bring you
to a halt so for example you should
write a really bad first draft
with no care about grammar or any of
that just get your ideas down doesn't
even matter the order
but get the first draft down and then so
you don't add it to begin with you
produce and once you've produced you can
add it and then re-edit and read it and
so forth but
just separating those two things is
extremely useful it's interesting you
say this because uh
what's the story about you when a guy on
quora
asked you a question about rules of life
and you came up with 42 you posted it
there and it got more shares and
conversation and it was you know talked
about and that kind of led to the whole
idea about
your 12 rules of life and beyond you
know yeah look what came out of that
yeah pretty absolutely absolutely yeah
it's it's it's staggering you know i
mean
i spent about well i spent about half an
hour writing those but i spent
like god only knows how long sure doing
the background thinking that enabled me
to write them and
yeah the the consequences of that were
just powerful
creative thinking just led to uh what it
led to today so if you like this sort of
short club from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye